c'est la dernière poche de résistance
ukrainien à marioupol azoff talent dans
les sous sols de cette immense usine
métallurgique deux à trois mille soldats
ukrainiens et des centaines de civils
sont encore retranché encerclé
assiégée par les forces russes qui
bombardent le complexe
il n'y aurait plus de 600 blessés un
commandant de l'armée ukrainienne appel
à l'évacuation
nous avons des civils avec nous il y en
a des centaines ici des dizaines
d'enfants beaucoup de personnes
handicapées des personnes âgées la
situation est très difficile il ya de
gros problèmes d'eau de nourriture de
médicaments de fournitures et d'armes
sauver la garnison de marioupol exfiltré
nous nous ne sommes pas en 1940 nous
sommes en 2022 les gens vont mourir ici
les blessés vont mourir et tous ceux qui
vivent encore vont être tués dans les
combats
les derniers combattants ukrainiens ont
toujours refusé de se rendre